all right so today we're gonna be doing
curbside consult with dr. Mike I know
that sounds fancy but all I'm really
gonna be doing is running up to people
and ask them is there anything I can do
for you how are you
know I'm a doctor is there anything I
can help you with hey pigeon I'm not a
vet but I'm a doctor hello
hi I'm a doctor and I was just wondering
if there's anything I can help you with
ladies say questions concerns I can
answer is that really cookie dough yeah
[Music]
how long should you go on to water Oh
so I think that's complete nonsense that
someone's mom said because one kid threw
up once if you do a lot of activity
whether that swimming running is going
into water your blood flow goes to that
area and doesn't go to your stomach so
you get an upset stomach but really you
can do it and nothing Bad's gonna happen
why what's wrong she's ready for the Gy
yeah that's what's up what is up yes
what is going on what's up guys okay
okay I was actually in a seven-year
accelerated program so I did one of
those three years undergrad yeah are you
ready to hear more question collagen
what about collagen makes up your skin
okay
I'm sorry to tell you this it doesn't do
anything
no so if the reason why they sell it and
why it's a great marketing ploy is that
if you're deficient in biotin which
pretty much anyone in the Western world
that eats a normal diet the balance site
is not notice you're not know because
biotin is readily available in like
meats and all the other stuff if you're
deficient yes your hair will start
falling out hello hi I'm a doctor I was
just wondering if you had any questions
one question
no okay four okay
yes coconut oil is safe down there in
fact women later in life because they
get some dryness that happens because
hormones decrease actually one of the
things I recommend and it works very
well in my patients is coconut oil
better than all of that refresh and all
the stuff that you buy over-the-counter
so coconut oil down there in fact I was
thinking I'm making this a product where
it's just like in a single serving that
you can just push it up there and I was
gonna call it cocoa badge
do you like cocoa veg once a day no okay
what is up I'm dr. Mike I'm nurse there
is it legal to give
generic try when I prescribe a medicine
on the bottom of the prescription pad
there's a thing that says da w which
means dispensed as written meaning if I
write a brand-name drug the pharmacist
and I check that box the pharmacist has
to give the brand-name drug and I don't
think there's much of difference between
the brand image absolutely not it's the
marketing companies that are geniuses
that say we have the name of the brand
so we're gonna make make sure everyone
asks for this viagra everyone knows
viagra is viagra put in a couple of
years when a Viagra loses its patent and
we can make a generic it's gonna be
sildenafil and guess what instead of
being a hundred dollars a pill it's
gonna be a dollar a pill Wow you're
gonna see guys walking around at
attention
okay whatever what about it is it really
the best for it depends obviously which
type of cancer we're talking about but
the new types of immune therapy that we
have the vaccinations the getting the
bacteria to eat the cancer alive all of
this stuff is just happening now and is
it the future how cool it would be if I
can give you a vaccine and say if you
get this vaccine you'll never get a
cancer that sounds pretty awesome right
the idea is that we don't jump too soon
and start doing something before we have
good research it's always we look at the
evidence first and then we figure it out
right boom what's up brother I'm a
doctor is there anything I can help you
out look today is it good to look use
two condoms on women
[Music]
never why they have a high chance of
breaking when you use two condoms really
kids stay with one condom yes totally
that's a good question what's up us
that's it I am a doctor thank you so
much what can I do to happy about what
question you got okay young guy I like
it okay one guy right in you
yeah right up such a pain
were you out of breath and what did you
do did it go away
eventually but it took some time so look
if it's just in one area and you're not
getting short of breath you're not
having chest pain probably nothing to
worry about but if you feel it moving up
to the chest 911 be you got it Bing Bing
nice for you watch the YouTube channel
we're filming actually today say hi to
YouTube do you do you have a good
medical question anyone ask me I get
like a lot of headaches at morning night
yeah morning every day yeah every day
come on every day yeah yeah
no I talked to my doctor and she said
it's because I was like water and you're
dehydrated how bad 1 to 10 is the
headache when you get it and what
happens you taking an Advil or something
Tylenol does it go away usually do you
wake up with it in the morning first
thing when you over all right so that's
a good sign actually the fact that you
don't wake up with it and the fact that
it goes to where the advil means it's
probably not scary do you eat well yeah
no what's the bad stuff you juices yeah
well that's a lot of sugar when you get
a lot of sugar going you get a headache
from that too so maybe when your
doctor's saying drink water she's really
saying drink less juice drink more water
in its motility and I'll count
for women the reason we say under 35 is
better is because the quality of the
eggs decrease in the number of eggs
actually doesn't decrease but it's just
the quality of the X that decreases it
increases the chance of things like
having a Down Syndrome child a lot of
these like really serious issues it
doesn't mean that women shouldn't get
pregnant after 35 in fact I encourage it
it just means that we need to take a
little bit more precaution take some
extra tests maybe do an extra ultrasound
somewhere in between but for guys yeah
it does there is a slowdown but it's not
as drastic and if a guy has a child at
35 versus a guy that has a child at 45
that risk of the Down syndrome and all
that doesn't happen curbside consult
with dr. Mike thank you so much this
will live on YouTube hey guys so we just
tried out this new concept trying to
prove that doctors or people too
we're relatable you could ask us any
question you want so if you like the
concept leave it down below in the
comments share this video with your
friends and again thanks for watching
okay awesome so now you're gonna be
there this is YouTube yes yeah you're
gonna be on the channel you found yeah
yeah yeah what's the title minute ow I
go in average right how long you think
it'll take for you to get laid that is a
medical question
[Music]